what we're saying what I'm saying at
least is that there should be an
evolutionary process to democracy as
there was in Hong Kong and you mentioned
that in the year 2017 Hong Kong will
have universal suffrage I think that
remains very much to be seen I doubt
very much whether there will be genuine
one man one vote but I would be
delighted to be proven wrong okay can I
answer that question I think it depends
on what you mean by democracy hmm i
don't think democracy centers just on
one man one vote i'm willing to concede
that at this stage maybe one man one
vote is a little too early but there are
the other aspects of democracy which I
believe to be important for all nation
and for all human beings and that is
human dignity some basic rights and
freedoms the right to participate in the
governance to improve the quality of
governance to have some say in issues
that affect their everyday life to have
the rule of law not the rule of men not
ruled by law and to have an independent
judiciary that is not subject to the
dictates of the one-party system rule
now I i agree with Martin that in the 3
30 years since open-door policy there
has been phenomenal economic growth
there has been a degree of personal
freedom and social mobility but the sad
fact is that in recent years market
economy reforms have stalled and the
government has backtracked on legal
reforms all judicial organs in China are
now subject to the dictates of the
one-party system room do we seriously
think that the population that the 1.3
billion people in mainland China are
content to accept this you say that
there are mass support for the one-party
system rule why is it then that we get
people in from mainland coming to Hong
Kong to participate in demonstration
particularly against the blind dissident
young young who was alleged to have
committed suicide